Traduttore: SILVIA ALLONE
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Questo è il pianeta Terra.
Questa meravigliosa sfera
blu, verde e bianca
è la culla dell'umanità,
dove la nostra civiltà è nata,
è cresciuta e si sta sviluppando.
La foto che vedete è stata scattata
dalla missione Apollo 17,
poco prima di arrivare sulla Luna,
negli anni Settanta.
Bellissima.
A me piace sempre vedere un po' più in là,
e quindi adesso vi porto con me
in un viaggio nel tempo:
un viaggio breve, un salto molto piccolo,
qualche decina d'anni nel futuro.
Questa è la Luna,
e quello che vedete è un albergo.
Tra qualche decina d'anni,
noi potremo prendere e farci
una settimana di vacanza sulla Luna:
ci sarà chi ci lavora,
e ci sarà chi ci va per svago.
Questa è un'idea reale,
è un progetto costato
diversi milioni di dollari,
di alcune catene di alberghi
tra le più famose al mondo.
Vi porto ancora più in là:
qualche altra decina d'anni nel futuro.
Qualcuno di voi, probabilmente,
avrà paura di volare.
Nessun problema: nello spazio
non ci sarà più bisogno di volare,
ci sarà un ascensore spaziale
che parte dalla Terra
e che arriva non solo
nelle stazioni orbitanti,
negli alberghi che abbiamo visto prima,
ma sarà una piattaforma
per spingersi ancora più in là.
Questo sistema di trasporto
permetterà di risparmiare
centinaia di milioni
di dollari in investimenti
su quello che oggi invece si utilizza,
quindi lanciatori per lanciare
in orbita i satelliti,
o i mezzi di trasporto attuali.
Di nuovo, facciamo un altro salto
in avanti, ancora qualche decina d'anni.
Il pianeta rosso, Marte,
come tutti noi lo conosciamo.
In realtà, quello che vedremo in futuro
non sarà una landa polverosa,
come quelle immagini dei rover
che oggi sono sulla superficie marziana.
Inizialmente ci saranno delle serre
dove coltiveremo del cibo per sopravvivere
e successivamente
il pianeta verrà terraformato
e ci vivremo come oggi
viviamo sulla Terra:
ci saranno boschi, ci sarà aria,
ci saranno dei parchi giochi,
ci saranno degli uffici.
Ma spingiamoci ancora in là,
facciamo un altro salto.
In futuro noi potremo
circolare liberamente
tra i pianeti del nostro sistema solare,
ad esempio utilizzando questa,
chiamiamola autostrada interplanetaria,
che utilizza un sistema
estremamente efficiente
di bilanciamento delle forze
gravitazionali dei vari pianeti
per spostarsi facilmente
da un pianeta all'altro.
E se volessimo andare ancora oltre,
immaginate dove l'essere umano
potrebbe essere,
potremmo colonizzare altri pianeti,
altri sistemi solari,
altre galassie.
Stiamo parlando, di centinaia,
forse migliaia di anni,
non importa.
Tutto questo esiste, sono piani,
sono progetti dove sono investiti
denari e cervelli,
quindi sono progetti reali
che verranno messi in pratica
nei prossimi anni,
nelle prossime decine,
magari centinaia di anni.
Peccato che tutto questo potrebbe davvero
rimanere solo nei libri di fantascienza.
Facciamo un salto indietro,
torniamo ad oggi,
torniamo alla nostra amatissima Terra
e vediamo cosa sta succedendo.
Queste immagini le conoscete.
Abbiamo disboscato
chilometri quadrati di foreste,
e le foreste producono ossigeno,
e l'ossigeno ci dà la vita,
ci permette di respirare.
Abbiamo inquinato l'acqua:
e un essere umano, senz'acqua,
non può che sopravvivere
per qualche giorno.
Abbiamo inquinato l'aria.
Allora l'aria, l'atmosfera
è una cosa spettacolare.
L'immagine della Terra prima,
l'avete vista, la Terra è grande,
ha un raggio di più di seimila chilometri;
l'atmosfera sono appena
un centinaio di chilometri.
Immaginate, è un guscio sottilissimo;
ed è quel guscio che ci permette
di vivere su questo pianeta.
Mi viene in mente una storiella
che mi racconta un amico carissimo,
ogni volta che vengo a Milano la racconta
perché sono ingegnere aerospaziale.
Fa più o meno così.
Ci sono due pianeti
che si incontrano nello spazio
e uno fa all'altro:
"Ciao Terra,
sono milioni di anni che non ti vedo.
E la Terra: "Eh, sì, sai com'è,
non è che passo di qua
proprio tutti i giorni".
"Terra, ma cosa succede,
ti vedo un po' pallida!"
Fa: "Guarda, non parlarmene,
sono stata dal dottore,
mi ha detto che mi
sono presa l'Homo Sapiens".
"Caspita, è grave?"
"Guarda no, grave no.
È un po' fastidioso,
ma non ti preoccupare:
il dottore mi ha detto
che tanto poi passa."
(Risate)
(Applauso)
Allora, in realtà noi esseri umani,
per fortuna, il cervello ce l'abbiamo,
quindi un po' queste cose
le stiamo capendo.
Di lavoro da fare ce n'è ancora tanto,
però abbiamo cominciato
e stiamo investendo
in energie rinnovabili,
abbiamo cominciato a ragionare,
a livello industriale,
a ciclo chiuso, in modo
da non avere impatti,
abbiamo capito l'importanza fondamentale
dei bisogni di ciascuno di noi,
che devono essere soddisfatti,
i bisogni primari;
e quindi qualcosa stiamo facendo.
Ma stiamo ancora, ovviamente,
mettendo le nostre mani
un po' in tutti i settori.
Abbiamo visto terra, abbiamo visto acqua,
abbiamo visto aria
e stiamo creando degli enormi danni
anche nello spazio,
quindi sto parlando dei detriti spaziali.
Attorno alla Terra, come vedete,
ci sono più di 6.000 satelliti;
solo 900 funzionano,
tutti gli altri sono lì
che vagano incontrollati
a 30.000 chilometri all'ora -
per intenderci,
stiamo parlando di trenta volte
la velocità di un proiettile -
a rischio di andare a sbattere
l'uno contro l'altro generando frammenti.
Ci sono già centinaia di milioni
di frammenti intorno alla Terra
e anche solo un piccolo pezzo di vernice
potrebbe passare da parte a parte
un satellite e distruggerlo.
Questi oggetti, girovagando,
diciamo, attorno alla Terra,
quelli più vicini alla Terra
prima o poi cadono.
Un oggetto sta per cadere,
nelle prossime 48 ore, sulla Terra,
ancora nessuno sa né dove né quando.
Quelli che vedete non sono, diciamo,
mobili da giardino un po' bizzarri,
sono satelliti, o pezzi di satelliti,
caduti vicino alle nostre case.
E questo è un problema
che continua a crescere.
Nei prossimi otto anni
lanceremo altri 1.200 satelliti
e la densità di questi oggetti,
attorno alla Terra,
sta crescendo con un trend esponenziale.
Si potrebbe arrivare ad una situazione
che aveva descritto Kessler,
che è uno scienziato NASA
che già dagli anni Settanta
stava ragionando sui detriti spaziali,
in cui si potrebbe creare
una collisione a catena
che porterebbe alla distruzione
di tutti i satelliti attorno alla Terra,
creando quindi una nube di detriti tale
per cui non riusciremmo più
a lanciare nulla,
non potremmo più mettere il naso
fuori dall'atmosfera,
perché questi detriti ci colpirebbero
e distruggerebbero qualsiasi cosa
noi tentassimo di mettere in orbita.
Allora qualcuno di voi penserà:
e chi se ne frega?
Abbiamo l'aria e l'acqua inquinata,
la terra inquinata,
abbiamo problemi sociali,
problemi politici,
chi se ne frega dello spazio.
Vero... ma non vero.
La maggior parte della tecnologia
che noi oggi utilizziamo,
in realtà arriva dallo spazio.
Vi ricordate, quando eravamo bambini
per chiamare negli Stati Uniti
bisognava chiamare un centralino,
prenotare la telefonata, farsi richiamare
e mettersi in comunicazione, poi,
con gli Stati Uniti.
Oggi chiunque di voi prende il cellulare
e chiama qualsiasi persona
in qualsiasi parte del mondo
in 0,5 secondi.
Quanti di voi prendono l'aereo
almeno una volta l'anno?
Immaginate quanto sarebbe difficile
spostarsi da un continente
all'altro senza GPS.
Pensate anche solo l'agricoltura,
i satelliti meteorologici,
i satelliti che monitorano gli oceani,
gli incendi, i terremoti,
i satelliti che danno una mano ai medici
nei paesi in via di sviluppo,
fornendo loro dati in tempo reale
dalle cliniche, magari,
degli Stati Uniti e dell'Europa.
Tutto questo potrebbe non esserci più,
tutto questo e molto altro.
Quindi, questo è quello
a cui potremmo arrivare.
Ci sono oggetti, al di fuori della Terra,
molto grandi, asteroidi:
uno è caduto in Russia poco tempo fa,
uno è caduto sulla Terra
60 milioni di anni fa
ed è grazie a quello
che noi come civiltà, come esseri umani,
siamo riusciti ad esistere,
portando però all'estinzione
una specie che c'era prima;
e questi oggetti viaggiano
intorno alla Terra.
Allora, immaginate la situazione:
noi siamo relegati su questo pianeta,
su questa meravigliosa astronave
che viaggia nel sistema solare,
però è l'unico posto dove noi siamo.
Questi oggetti continuano
ad incrociare le nostre traiettorie.
Questi grossi asteroidi,
grandi chilometri,
potrebbero venirci addosso;
e noi non sappiamo
che effetto potrebbero avere,
potrebbero portarci all'estinzione.
Noi dobbiamo avere la capacità,
come abbiamo fatto dai tempi dei Fenici,
di espanderci, di trovare
nuovi posti dove poter vivere.
E dobbiamo farlo in modo intelligente,
altrimenti rischieremo,
tra 50 anni o 100 anni,
di non esserci più.
Spaventati.
In realtà, l'obiettivo non è di farvi fare
queste facce di spavento.
L'obiettivo è dirvi sì signori,
abbiamo un problema,
un problema di cui magari qualcuno di voi
neanche aveva sentito parlare,
un problema invisibile
sopra le nostre teste,
però c'è qualcuno che ci sta pensando.
Ci sono organizzazioni internazionali,
c'è NASA, l'Agenzia Spaziale Europea,
grandi aziende che operano
nel settore spaziale,
che stanno progettando queste missioni
per andare a recuperare i satelliti morti.
Ci sono ancora diversi problemi.
Uno, la tecnologia.
La tecnologia oggi ancora non esiste:
non esiste il sistema, fatto e finito,
per andare a recuperare.
Non si sa come fare.
Ci sono problemi politici e legali.
Oggi un russo non può rimuovere
un satellite americano,
un americano non può rimuovere
un satellite cinese
ed anche questo è da risolvere;
e soprattutto c'è un problema di base,
c'è un problema di prospettiva.
Questi sistemi, queste grosse
missioni ultracomplicate,
prevedono di riuscire a rimuovere,
da cinque a dieci satelliti all'anno,
ma abbiamo detto prima
che ne lanciano almeno 100 ogni anno,
quindi 100 su e 10 giù.
C'è qualcosa che non torna.
Queste soluzioni da sole non bastano.
Bisogna fare un cambio di prospettiva.
Bisogna ragionare in modo sistemico
e fare in modo che tutto ciò
che noi lanciamo nello spazio,
come primo passo, possa essere rimosso
quando non serve più.
Ed è qui che qui entriamo in campo
noi, noi di D Orbit,
società che ho fondato due anni fa
e che sta sviluppando
dei motori intelligenti
da attaccare sui satelliti,
in modo tale da rimuovere i satelliti
a fine vita, quando non servono più,
in modo rapido, controllato e sicuro.
Questa idea, come tantissime idee,
è nata da un sogno,
il sogno di andare nello spazio.
Ad un certo punto, lungo
il mio percorso verso lo spazio,
mi sono reso conto che lo spazio
non potrebbe più
essere disponibile per me,
ma neanche per nessun altro.
Ho detto: beh, aspetta,
se davvero voglio andare nello spazio
cerchiamo di riuscire a rimanerci
almeno per più che qualche secondo.
E quindi ho cominciato
a pensare a una soluzione,
che non fosse la soluzione classica
di andare a recuperare i satelliti,
ma pensando ad un percorso,
un percorso che potesse permettere a noi
di arrivare a quel futuro
che vi ho mostrato prima.
Quindi, con questo pezzo di carta
sono volato in Silicon Valley,
negli Stati Uniti,
ho fatto un periodo in NASA
e da lì quell'idea, quel concetto
è diventato un piano industriale.
Nel 2010 sono rientrato in Italia,
ho trovato un fondo
di investimento italiano, Venture Capital,
che ha creduto da subito nell'idea
e che ancora oggi ci accompagna,
e insieme con altri tre italiani,
che lavoravano in altre aziende europee
nel settore spazio,
a marzo del 2011 è nata l'azienda,
questa azienda che oggi ha 13 persone,
tutte appassionatissime di spazio
e con una gran voglia
di fare la differenza,
di avere un impatto positivo
sulla società.
Queste persone lavorano per assicurare
un accesso pulito e sicuro allo spazio.
Dicevo, il nostro dispositivo
è un motore intelligente,
quindi dotato di una certa intelligenza,
e funziona in maniera abbastanza semplice:
si installa sul satellite,
il satellite va in orbita,
fa quello che deve fare,
quindi telecomunicazioni,
foto della Terra -
Quando finisce, da Terra
è possibile comandare direttamente
il nostro satellite che lo spinge:
se il satellite è vicino alla Terra
lo fa rientrare in atmosfera, dove brucia,
oppure lo spinge in un'orbita
di parcheggio più lontana,
dove non può creare danni a nessuno,
in attesa che magari in futuro,
con una tecnologia che oggi non c'è,
possano essere recuperati questi satelliti
e magari riciclati direttamente in orbita.
Chiaramente è un dispositivo che:
deve essere indipendente dal satellite;
deve funzionare anche quando
il satellite non funziona;
e soprattutto, deve rimuovere
il satellite in poco tempo.
Pensate che oggi è ammesso rimuovere
un satellite vicino alla Terra in 25 anni.
Ma abbiamo detto prima
che la densità di questi detriti
sta aumentando in modo esponenziale,
non abbiamo 25 anni;
noi li rimuoviamo in 40 minuti.
Se qualcuno di voi sta pensando
di comprarsi un satellite
e volesse metterci a bordo
il nostro dispositivo,
non solo non avrebbe più problemi,
grattacapi per la rimozione del satellite,
ma potrebbe addirittura farci più soldi;
e questo è un vantaggio
per chi oggi, invece, il problema lo crea.
E se, invece,
qualcun altro non fosse interessato
a comprare un satellite,
ma fosse interessato
ad un'assicurazione sulla vita
contro la caduta dei satelliti
che abbiamo visto prima,
Anche su quello non vi preoccupate,
perché quando noi li rimuoviamo
sappiamo esattamente
dove stanno andando a cadere.
Dicevo, il progetto è nato nel 2011,
nel 2012 abbiamo realizzato
il primo dimostratore che abbiamo testato,
queste sono alcune immagini
del test che abbiamo fatto in Germania
e quest'anno, quindi
un anno di differenza,
abbiamo qualificato il cervello
del nostro dispositivo
per farlo funzionare nello spazio,
quindi per resistere
ai carichi, alle forze,
alle vibrazioni del lanciatore;
e poi per farlo funzionare
nel mondo spaziale.
Adesso, tra due settimane,
questo oggetto verrà mandato
in orbita dalla Russia
e verrà testato nello spazio.
Quindi il passo successivo
sarà la commercializzazione del prodotto
e riuscire ad installarlo
su tutti i satelliti
che partiranno da oggi in poi.
Questo è il nostro piccolo
ma fondamentale contributo,
è il primo passo,
per risolvere i problemi
dei detriti spaziali,
che noi consideriamo veramente
un collo di bottiglia
per tutto lo sviluppo dell'attività
commerciale del pianeta Terra.
Tra qualche centinaio di anni, nel futuro,
ci guarderemo indietro
e probabilmente sorrideremo,
un po' come facciamo oggi
pensando al Medioevo,
sorrideremo pensando
a quanto fosse, in realtà, facile
progettare le nostre attività umane,
di svago, di business,
in modo intelligente,
costruttivo e strategico.
Quello che possiamo fare però noi oggi,
sempre su questa meravigliosa sfera blu,
sulla nostra astronave Terra,
noi oggi abbiamo la capacità
di poter progettare il nostro futuro,
di volere un futuro
che sia capace di futuro,
quindi sappiamo dove vogliamo arrivare
e conosciamo bene quello
che abbiamo a disposizione,
perché tutte le risorse
che abbiamo a disposizione
sono lì, sono su questa sfera.
Quindi sappiamo dove dobbiamo arrivare,
sappiamo da dove possiamo partire.
A questo punto ciascuno di noi,
ognuno nel proprio ambito,
può rimboccarsi le maniche,
chi a casa, chi opera sulla terra,
chi opera sull'acqua, chi opera nell'aria
e chi opera nello spazio,
per creare un futuro capace di futuro.
Quindi grazie a tutti e buon lavoro.
(Applausi)